hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the
economic status of the Beloved Wizarding
family the Weasleys in a world full of
magic where seemingly anything is
possible it might surprise you to hear
that even witches and wizards can face
financial hardship the Advent of magical
abilities makes life easier and
certainly a lot more interesting in a
lot of ways but one limitation of note
is that gold cannot be multiplied the
result is that even magical families who
can do amazing things like fly through
the air summon objects with the flick of
their wand and teleport can find
themselves in financial Dire Straits
within the novel there are numerous
examples of fan favorite witches and
wizards exemplifying this one example
being Remus Lupine The Stranger was
wearing an extremely shabby set of
wizards robes that had been darned in
several places he looked ill and
exhausted though quite young his light
brown hair was flecked with gray
but perhaps the greatest example of
Wizarding poverty that is alluded to
time and time again is the Weasley
family the nine-person strong Wizarding
family that Embraces Harry with open
arms right near the beginning of the
first book these nine family members are
Arthur Molly Bill Charlie Percy Fred
George Ron and Ginny there are numerous
passages referencing their lack of
wealth and their poverty seems to be
pretty consistent throughout the books
as early as the first books Draco Malfoy
and his father Lucius condescendingly
mocked the family while heavily implying
that they are poor think my name's funny
do you well no need to ask yours red
hair and a hand-me-down robe you must be
a Weasley let's see red hair vacant
Expressions Tatty secondhand book you
must be the Weasleys and in the Chamber
of Secrets Harry Ventures into the
Weasley family Vault and Witnesses first
hand just how dire their financial
situation really was Harry and enjoyed
the Breakneck Journey Down to the
Weasley's Vault but felt Dreadful far
worse than he had knocked her an alley
when it was opened there was a very
small pile of silver sickles inside and
just one gold Galleon Mrs Weasley felt
right into the corners before sweeping
the whole lot into her bag and what
makes their poverty even more evident is
the fact that it's constantly contrasted
with Harry's massive Fortune we're
approaching the Wizarding World very
much from the perspective of Harry who
has no Financial woes whatsoever right
in the beginning of the first book we
shown Harry's massive stacks of gold in
Vault 687 but what I want to explore now
is why why are the Weasleys so poor how
is it that they're living in such
derelict conditions they're a pure blood
family with deep ties in The Wizarding
World Martha has a good job at a
long-standing Wizarding institution and
seemingly there's an abundance of family
members with the ability to contribute
to the family's income let's dive in are
they actually that poor first things
first are they actually that poor I'm
sure there is a distinct emphasis placed
on their Tatty clothes and lack of cash
but are they really as poverty-stricken
as we are led to believe personally I
don't think so while it's clear that
unexpected expenses seem to be a point
of stress for the Weasley family like
Hogwarts School Supplies textbooks Etc
there are other lifestyle indicators
that would suggest money is not as tight
as it may seem the first thing that I
want to highlight is that all members of
the Weasley family are well fed they all
seem to have at least three Square meals
a day and at no point is food not an
option for them the same cannot be said
for other characters like Remus Lupine
who appears to be malnourished before
arriving at Hogwarts in the Prisoner of
Azkaban he was as shabby as ever but
looked healthier than he had on the
train as though he had had a few Square
meals to me this perfectly exemplifies
the levels of poverty present in the
Wizarding World maybe they were in
financial director rates but food on the
table puts them rung above those who are
truly at the bottom the next thing that
I want to highlight is how they spend
their money in the Prisoner of Azkaban
the Weasleys win the daily profit grand
prize Galleon draw an annual contest
held by the daily Prophet through this
contest the Weasley's won a considerable
amount of gold galleons but did they
spend it fixing their house buying new
clothes for their kids no they spent it
on a family-wide month-long summer
holiday to visit their son bill in Egypt
when they came back from the trip they
had enough galleons left over to Byron a
new wand but apart from Ron's wand all
of the money was spent on the trip
bearing all this in mind I can't help
but ask myself if they were truly in the
dire Financial State highlighted by the
books then was this the best possible
use for this money surely if money was
as tight as is described then this money
should have been directed towards
Necessities lastly I think it's
important to take note of the fact that
the Weasleys were able to treat their
children on occasion like buying Ron a
broom when he makes prefect and Percy an
owl if we consider all of the above it
paints a picture of a normal family
where money is a bit tight and not a
poverty-stricken family that's
struggling to make ends meet are they a
bit strapped for cash sure but immersed
in poverty certainly not income the next
thing I want to discuss is the Weasley
family income provided that for the
duration of the books most of their
children are enrolled at Hogwarts the
burden of providing for the family falls
on the parents Molly and Arthur however
Molly takes on the role of stay-at-home
mum leaving Arthur with the
responsibility of being the primary
earner for the entire family after
Weasley worked for the ministry of Magic
and was head of the misuse of Michael
artifacts Department it was his job to
regulate the use of Magic on muggle
objects and to prevent Bewitched items
from falling into muggle hands later on
however he was promoted to the head of
office for the detection and
confiscation of counterfeit defensive
spells and protective objects
departments we aren't actually provided
with in-depth information on how much
Arthur makes but if we consider their
economic standing it can't be that much
however what's particularly unusual
about this is that Arthur in both of his
roles is head of a department presumably
Arthur in a position of authority the
ministry should be compensated
accordingly as it happens there are a
few factors that may have influenced
Arthur's salary the first big issue for
Arthur was that Cornelius fudge was his
boss it's well known that Arthur and
Cornelius did not get along and so it's
not unlikely that fudge inhibited
Arthur's salary and career progression
even if Arthur excelled in his role it's
likely that fudge got in the way of
raises and promotions it wasn't until
1996 that fudge was out of office which
meant that for the majority of his
children's lives before they became
adults Arthur was professionally stunted
because of fudge Arthur was effectively
stuck in a dead-end job without much
chance of progression supporting a
family of seven children and a wife
expenses most of the time income level
is not the sole factor in determining
whether or not someone is poor in fact
someone could have an extremely healthy
salary and still be poor provided that
their expenses are equally as high in
the case of Arthur he had a lot of
expenses the most significant expense
for Arthur was undoubtedly his children
and all of the expenses that come with
having children for starters every
single one of the Weasley children
attended Hogwarts and while Hogwarts is
Affordable in some way ways tuition is
free school supplies and materials are
not especially at scale buying ones
books brooms and all sorts of other
school supplies on top of taxes bills
Insurance food clothes robes and even
fines flying Ford Anglia incident comes
at a heavy price and given that Arthur
was the Sole Provider for the family
it's certainly not surprising that the
Weasleys were under some level of
financial stress bearing that in mind
however I think the next question we
need to tackle is why Molly didn't work
as well well I think the most obvious
answer to this is that with seven
children you have to have a parent
around to maintain order with both Molly
and Arthur working who are supposed to
take care of the kids while there may
have been intermittent periods for Molly
to work like when the kids were away at
school I'm sure that she had more than
enough responsibilities around the house
to keep herself busy conclusion if we
consider everything I've said so far in
this video I think it's safe for me to
disclose the following conclusions one
they aren't that poor two their expenses
are significant three they just don't
care about money I'm sure the Weasleys
may have been portrayed as poor but the
messaging certainly doesn't stop there
if the Harry Potter books are anything
to go by then it's clear that money
isn't everything if we can trust the
happy thriving and loving but poor
Weasley family with the cold snarky and
miserable but Rich Malfoy family I think
we have an answer as to how important
money really is the Weasley family was a
perfect representation of how love and
companionship can be far more valuable
than money they may not have had the
wealth of the malfoys but they were
wealthy in love and happiness the
Weasley family's financial situation
made them appreciate the little things
in life and they were thankful for what
they had an abundance of Love warmth and
companionship and that's it for this
video if you enjoy the content please
like the video and subscribe to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to dreams and forget to live